what is candlestow candles tau is a
correlation coefficient and this does a
measure of the relationship between two
variables but what is the difference
between Pierson correlation and candle's
rank correlation in contrast to Pearson
correlation candle's rank correlation is
a non-parametric test procedure thus for
the calculation of candlest Tau the data
need not to be normally distributed and
the two variables need only have ordinal
scale levels exactly the same is true
for the spiemen Rand correlation right
candlest tau is very similar to
spearman's rank correlation coefficient
however candlest Tau should be preferred
over spearman's correlation if very few
data with many ranked ties are available
but how is candle style calculated we
can calculate candle Style with this
formula where C is the number of
concordant pairs and D is the number of
discordant pairs what are concordant and
discordant pairs